[Music]
this is a visualization of the different
paths the key figures took during the
course of the great calamity it's based
on the information provided to us by
creating a champion
as well as different cut scenes from
breath of the wild over the course of
this demonstration we will pause the
narrative at various moments to analyze
and cross-reference this information
with some of the cutscenes seen in the
trailer of the newly announced hyrule
warriors
age of calamity the goal is to see if
this holds up to the pre-existing
knowledge of the event as well as
provide possible scenarios for the
aforementioned game
so anytime you see this text pop up we
will sketch a possible gameplay scenario
and make best guesses on how this might
turn out this is part 1 of a 7 part
series which will be published up until
the 26th of september when we are
supposedly getting more information
about the sequel to hyrule warriors
when all parts are released there will
be a full version available with all
characters included the one you are
watching right now will focus on lincoln
zelda and i will be joined by none other
than nintendo black crisis in this part
he too will be posting his own video
which focuses on the lore comparisons
between breath of the wild and hyrule
warriors age of calamity as well as
story predictions for the game
so be sure to check that one out too the
link will be in the description
a couple of things to note this series
will only cover the events
during the great calamity itself from
the moment it starts until the moment
zelda seals ganon inside hyrule castle
any moments before or after
are simply too speculative and we don't
have enough information about these
events
this includes any monster attacks that
may have occurred before calamity ganon
rose up from the castle
additionally we will focus solely on the
key players in the story and their
actions during the disaster
it will not feature detailed
descriptions of battles taking place
or the fate of the many towns villages
and garrisons
with that said let's get into it
despite being dubbed the day of the
great calamity the event itself doesn't
actually last throughout the whole day
at sunrise zelda travels to the
promenade with four of the five
champions accompanying her
as according to ravali's diary he
himself arrived much later
from here she scales mount leneru to
pray at the spring of wisdom
with link watching over her at sundown
ravali has finally joined the party
link and zelda return from the summit
and are greeted by the four pilots
after some conversation the earth starts
to tremble and the sky in the distance
starts to glow in eerie red color rivali
flies up to see what's happening
and witnesses the ghostly figure that is
calamity ganon
swirling around above hyrule castle this
officially marks the beginning of the
calamity
and this is where our analysis begins
after briefly discussing their strategy
the party splits up into different
directions
linc and zelda traverse the promenade
through the canyon and towards kakariko
village
after crossing the village they make
their way down sahasrara's slope and
follow hylia river past the linearu
wetlands
they reach rabone bridge and cross into
central hyrule
through may prairie and towards the
gates of hyrule castletown
by the time they arrive hyrule castle is
burning and the town square is about to
be ravaged by guardians
they quickly realize that the castle and
town
are beyond saving creating a champion
does not specify how long link and zelda
lingered on the central square
it's highly likely that age of calamity
will make this a playable section in
which link and zelda desperately try to
fight off as many enemies as possible
this way they grant some of the soldiers
and civilians a chance to escape the
city
it's also likely that they will be
joined by impa in this fight based
on this still frame where they are seen
in front of the gates of castletown with
impa at their side
after realizing the town is lost the duo
is forced to make the difficult decision
of leaving their friends and family to
their fate
and prioritize their own survival at
this point the guardians are about to
spill out into the green fields of
central hyrule through the main gate
as well as the east and west gate of
castletown towards the quarry and
to akala citadel in pursuit of the
fleeing population
link and zelda make their way to mabe
village and its nearby ranch
as its closest neighbors to castle town
these are the first two settlements to
come under siege by the machines
unlike most regular villages across
hyrule mabe village seems to be well
defended as seen from this screenshot
the town has a wall
and a gate and from studying the ruins
of mabe village we can find multiple
dead guardians
something that's exceptionally rare to
see in the other destroyed villages
it's possible that age of calamity will
see link and zelda take part in the
defense of the village for a while
before continuing onwards
after crossing mabe village the two once
again crossed the mabe prairie
however unlike the previous route they
took when they were on the way to the
castle
something interesting happens right as
they are about to cross the rabone
bridge
they make an abrupt turn and head south
along the other side of the hylia river
this sudden change of direction
indicates that the guardians approaching
from the north and northeast
forced them to change course this falls
in line with the attack on gapunga
village which is situated in the lenairu
wetlands
by the time the duo reaches the bridge
the guardians which rushed from the east
gate had likely already reached the
other side of the river
pushing them south in all likelihood
linc and zelda originally planned to
take the same route they did
before up the hash's slope and towards
kakariko village
it's the most logical option for a safe
haven and impa likely urged
zelda to rendezvous at the village with
their intended escape route now blocked
the two moved south
sticking to the riverbank and avoiding
major settlements their goal is to reach
fort hattino the only defensive line on
the way to east nekluda
inside a forest close to the bottomless
swamp zelda briefly breaks down with
link comforting her
but with no time to lose and guardians
on the way she regains her footing and
they continue to move down hilaia river
across horwell bridge and towards the
dueling peaks
from central hyrule an evacuation route
has been set up from the hyrule exchange
all the way to hateno village with
guardians still on their tail lincoln
zelda crossed the squabble river and
joined the evacuation line
age of calamity might turn this pursuit
into an actual gameplay section
where link and zelda may need to stand
their ground and hold back the incoming
guardians in order to keep the
evacuating citizens safe
as the two join the tail end of the
evacuation line they cross between the
dueling peaks
and onto black cherry plain they reach
fort hattano
and this is where the duo makes their
final stand with the help of the fort's
militia they fend off volley after
volley of incoming guardians
each wave takes its toll on our hero
link until finally
he can take no more obviously out of all
memories in breath of the wild link's
final stand
is one of the most iconic moments and
saved for last for a good reason
the defense of fort hattano will most
likely be made playable as either link
or
zelda though in this case link would
definitely be a more fitting choice
after completing this chaotic battle we
will likely transition to the infamous
scene
totally exhausted the hero is about to
make his final sacrifice
and fulfill his duty to protect the
princess one of the guardians detects
his presence and is about to extinguish
his fire once and for all when zelda's
sacred sealing power springs to life
a blast of energy surges across the
fields of blachery plane
and the guardians in its vicinity are no
more
despite this victory for the mortally
wounded link it seems to be too late
he collapses in zelda's arms and just as
all hope seems lost
zelda receives a message from within the
master sword what words were spoken
exactly is unknown as only zelda is able
to hear the message
but it suggests that link can still be
saved if placed in the shrine of
resurrection
with zelda not showing up at kakariko
village according to the plan
the worried impa has dispatched shika
warriors to locate the princess
two of which arrive just in time to aid
her she instructs them to take link back
to the shrine of resurrection
as she feels his survival is key to the
defeat
of calamity gannon from this moment the
paths of the hero and princess diverge
as link is being carried to the shrine
of resurrection along with the sheikah
slate
zelda takes the heavily damaged master
sword and makes her way to kakariko
village to discuss a new strategy
she then sets off on a dangerous journey
alone towards hyrule's great
forest once again she traverses a
sahasrara slope
and moves north this time crossing
them's bridge into tribbly plain
through the minchi woods and into the
forest there
she lay the master sword to rest at the
foot of the great deku tree
after a brief conversation with the
guardian of the forest
she sets off towards hyrule castle past
the military training ground
roru settlement then crosses the
helmhead and boneyard bridge and through
the east gate of castletown
she arrives at her final destination and
stands face to face with the scourge
of hyrule castle calamity ganon
she raises her hand and with a bright
flash of light seals herself
along with the demon kane inside the
castle
zelda's journey is one of if not the
most important moment which took place
during the calamity
there is a high probability that this
section will be playable
although zelda's move set seems to
revolve around the use of the sheikah
slate as seen in the trailer
she will most likely wield her sacred
power in this section of the game
perhaps in the form of the bow of light
or simply by creating energy blasts to
rid her of the enemies standing in her
way
meanwhile as zelda is on our way to
hyrule castle link has arrived at the
great plateau and is placed inside the
shrine of resurrection
additionally impa has instructed pura
and robbie to join them as their
expertise and knowledge of the facility
is needed to operate it
link is laid to rest and the sheikah
slade is placed inside a pedestal
alongside him in hopes that it will be
of use to him when he finally wakes up
the moment zelda sealed ganon inside the
castle the events of the calamity
largely came to a halt
forced into a dormant state he loses
direct control over the guardians and
divine beasts
the beasts shut down and become inactive
as for the guardians
those who are still operational either
retreat back to hyrule castle
or mindlessly wander the landscape
without a clear purpose
[Music]
you